all right we're here tonight in southern
california for our exclusive interview
with caitlyn jenner running
uh to be the next governor of the great
state of california to replace gavin
newsom
let me just ask you about law and order
that we have you watch the riots this
this summer some democrats media people
wouldn't acknowledge their riots
i have statistics in l.a 465 shootings
since january
1st up 67 from last year
homicides up 26 when you look at l.a
county
and outside the city of los angeles well
homicides up a whopping 113 percent
and gavin newsom is going to release 76
000
additional inmates for good behavior 63
000 of them
committed violent crimes would you do
that
not at all i think
on the releasing of the prisoners
criminal justice reform is very
important
and we need to do that okay we need to
rehabilitate people
in prison and bring them back into the
community safely
in his case i don't know how many of
these people have actually been
rehabilitated
to go back into society um
and so i am 100
behind our police force every place i go
um if i see a cop if i'm driving and i
see a cop i'll put my hand out the
window and give him a thumbs up
um if i'm there sitting there i'll pull
up and say hey thank you for your
service you know this citizen
appreciates what you do
um i 100 support our police forces
um uh as far as
i would be very tough
uh on writing um
using as many forces as i could possibly
use to stop the writing protect the
citizens and the businesses of this
community
um i think that's extremely important
the national guard
whatever we need to keep peace what is
the police reform then that you want
the only police reform i think we need
look at in
every business out there there's good
people and there's bad people probably
shouldn't be do
be there no matter if you're a
journalist
okay no matter what the business is the
mob and the go ahead yeah yeah no matter
what it is you're gonna get good and bad
i think proper training be able to weed
out the good with the bad
um i have a very good friend of mine who
was in the sheriff's departments for
years
and we talk a lot about this issue and i
was talking the other day about it and
he said you know what the sad part is
the sheriff's department's training
center is like
almost empty nobody wants to be a cop
anymore
do you blame them after i cannot blame
them i do not blame them but
as from sacramento that has to change
um this is important how how do you
change that in other words like i for
example
i would suggest more training and oh
yeah you know i i would
i would look for more non-lethal options
i think would be a good idea
but defunding dismantling
who my question to people who are you
gonna call
i totally agree um
it's just a stupid idea again no common
sense in sacramento
gavin newsom no common sense to release
prisoners into the community
and then say they're going to defund the
police i support the police 100 percent
i
support the national guard i support our
business owners in los angeles and
around the country
um and would do everything i can to
protect them
we we have other issues for example
gavin newsom talks about taxing water i
did a show from san joaquin valley
oh i'm just doing my research uh
i know the delta smelt prevented farmers
from being able to farm
it's not a small deal this is farms now
i
i've heard about the delta smelt yes how
would you what would you do on that case
water's a big issue in this state it is
okay it's a big issue in the state to be
honest with you
i mean every year i follow just as a
resident i follow what the waterfall is
i used to have a home in tahoe how much
snowfall do we have there because that's
where the bulk of our water comes from
and every year i see this guy go out and
he's on the news and he has this big
long pole
and he takes it out of this field that
he sticks it down to see what the
how much snow we have you know this year
was only down maybe you know
three or four feet others days it's been
like 10 feet where he's like pushing the
pole down you're thinking oh we're in
pretty good shape
our water system's going up and down all
the time
this year we're down we've gotten here
in the los angeles area
really probably only two good rainfalls
and you can see that from my house you
can see how
the vegetation is very you know it's not
green it's just
because it just hasn't got much water we
are headed for a trout
um that has to be looked at in advance
here's my crazy thinking again sean
logical thinking we are now spending
billions of dollars on this high-speed
rail
okay they talk about it all the time
between
l.a and san francisco and
um i'm going why are we doing that
uh i can get on a plane at lax and i'll
be in san francisco in 50 minutes
you know why do we need high-speed rail
why don't we do this
why don't we invest that money in
desalinization plants along the coast
take that water and any time it's a bad
year desalinate the water
have some pipes going over the mountains
out to the san joaquin valley
for all our farmers have it down here
we're in the camarillo area
you look right over here i drive through
the farm yards every year
why don't we just start to look at it
wait a second maybe water is a bigger
issue than trying to move a few people
believe it or not fast 33 years ago when
i started my radio career that was a big
issue in santa barbara
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else